on the picket line and getting plenty of
support from passing motorists nurses
and ambulance workers on strike together
for the first time pushing for a pay
rise in line with inflation
Jason Jeffrey Works in a cardiac unit
here for him it's all about Staffing
levels
for me it was never about money it was
about delivering care and making sure
that I can make a difference to
somebody's life even if it's one person
we just want to be able to provide that
care that I set out to and I've studied
really hard for
National Health Service bosses are now
urging the UK government to reopen pay
talks for the current year for England
like the devolved Welsh and Scottish
governments have done an ambulance work
as a rejected claims they're not
attending urgent cases on strike days
saying they're leaving picket lines to
do so we have not spoken to the
government for the past month we have
however spoken to the government in
Wales and the government in Scotland we
are making progress in negotiations in
Wales in Scotland and that's why we are
not in Striking Wheels in Scotland today
well this might be the biggest NHS
strike so far but it's certainly not the
last and while these striking workers
say they are pushing for a fair pay rise
they say they're also doing it for the
sake of their patients patients like
Laurel a retired counselor who's seen
the effect of increased Demand on NHS
workers she's currently waiting for an
ultrasound and also needs a hip
replacement but backs the strikes even
if they delay her treatment
sometimes it's painful sometimes a good
day bad day so I feel it can wait
but I won't be able to wait for the
operation forever you know it will get
worse and now I'm worried I'm frightened
that
you know there won't be any nurses left
there won't be an NHS left
to do that operation
[Music]
[Applause]
for now it's a standoff adding to the
record waiting lists and to Growing
public anger over the state of the
National Health Service Nadine barber Al
Jazeera Brighton in Southern England